i know maybe
tonight didn't go the way you wanted but
how are you feeling you competed till
the very end of big brother how are you
feeling
i um you know of course i'm disappointed
um i really really wanted to get in
those final two chairs but i'm very
proud of my performance um i'm i really
came in this game to play and i put my
all i played with my heart um so i can
only just be but happy at where i'm at
i'm also really really happy about the
winner i think it's
incredibly very well deserved um and i'm
so happy to have taken part in you know
helping crown an african-american winner
for the first time in bb us history
um i want to get to all of that but i
want to sort of go through the the
evening all right so obviously you you
know you lost part three of hoh did you
know that xavier was probably gonna pick
derek or was there a part of you that
thought maybe
he'll pick me to go to final two
no i knew immediately when i lost hoh
that he'd be picking victi
i knew that because we had both talked
to each other and um
he had told me he was considering taking
me
i had told him i think you should honor
with your deal and even if i have my own
reservations as to what i want to do
because i hadn't made a deal with either
of them i never want to be the person
that imposes on that so um i came into
the hoh knowing it was now or never for
me and if i did not win that hoh i
wasn't going to be in those final two
chairs
um so
the the next part i want to talk to you
about is is there a point in the game
that you look back on and you think okay
i mean obviously you know hoh part three
but is there something before that that
you look back on and you wish you had
done differently or something that you
wish that you just slightly tweaked in
your game
i um so in my final five hoh um my
target was hannah um i don't regret
targeting hannah because of the deals
that i had made i had a final three with
x and big b and me and kylan basically
had a ceasefire that i wouldn't come
after him until final four she
unfortunately was just a casualty of war
where i regret was that i lied to her i
think that put a mark in my gameplay
because up until then i played an honest
game um what i'm really happy to know is
that hannah told me after that i didn't
care that you did that and if you were
in those final two chairs i would have
voted for you so um that was something
that was rolling in my head for a really
long time but i'm happy that she was
completely at peace with it and didn't
take any type of way that's the one
thing i would change
yeah i think when kylian was the next
one to walk through the door i think
that def versus you you know kyle was
you know the
um the one evicted at final four i think
that definitely
changed things for hannah a little bit
at least that's what i got when i was
watching this show um
so
why i mean i i feel like it's kind of
obvious but why did you vote for x what
exactly about his game just really stood
out to you
um i you know
when i got to final three um i wanted to
take my best friend that's what i wanted
to do um but something about being in a
house for a long time you start to think
you think about the amount of money that
is you think about the history that
we're making and you really take a look
at
gameplay from beginning to end um i
voted for x because i didn't feel he
definitely didn't deserve third place um
i think time and time again when asked
in difficult situations he put the
alliance before himself he threw
competitions when he could have won them
he won competition we really needed him
to um and i think he overall exemplified
a really really good big brother player
um at the bottom of my heart it didn't
feel comfortable for me to
um
to go for this amount of money and leave
him in third it just didn't sit right
with me and that's why
i made the decision if i were to win i
would take him um i didn't have that exp
i didn't place that expectation on him
for me but i just think he played the
game incredibly well and um
as a fan of the game i have to respect
and honor that
i feel like that is something you know
people watching you know and i you know
it's always you know this is i think fan
experience just in general but
everyone's watching like no you got to
do the thing that's going to get you the
750 000
you know so so you say you really would
have taken xavier with you even if it
meant you losing that money i when i
tell you i was agonizing and rolling
over this decision for days i was
big d cried to me because he felt like i
betrayed him as a friend but
it's very easy to watch this game and
think things but when you're in this
house
you start to think all right if i did
that
10 15 years that's a huge amount of
money that is going to change me for the
rest of my life if i look back 10 15 20
years from now am i going to still feel
comfortable with that decision that i
took that way
how i played the game the entire time
was i played with my heart and i never
took the easy way out i always held
myself accountable when i needed to
and um i had to at the bottom of my
heart i'm like this guy doesn't deserve
dirt i don't feel like he deserves third
and you know i'm not gonna sit there and
try to push myself into his final two
chairs if he wins but i gotta hold
myself accountable and go ahead and say
you know what you can have this if
people feel are the best of us that's
fine but for me for me to feel
comfortable with myself that's the
decision i would have to make
well we obviously have to talk about the
history that was made this evening um
obviously with xavier becoming the first
black house guest to win big brother
what does it mean to you to be a part of
that but also recognizing that this is
happening in the 23rd season like it's
taken 23 seasons to get here yeah i mean
it's um it it has taken some time to get
here but i am
i'm someone who i've been a fan of the
show so
um i applied last year i applied the
year beforehand um and i didn't get on
but i am so incredibly like lucky to
have been on this season i mean
if there's a season that i could have
come on i'm so happy that it's this one
it's great and um what i just love the
most of it all is that i will of course
i wanted an african-american to win i
wanted to be the one that won um but
when we all walked in that door
um i think we all similar felt similar
ways yeah went after himself what do you
mean
but to
put personal game aside through the
weeks and literally strategized to get
everyone to six no matter how much we
felt about this person no matter how
much ups and downs
it's
the fact that i could be a part of this
as a big brother fan i'm just like yo
this is great like i like like this is
like this is more than a brigade this is
more than like all those alliances like
this is this is crazy so as a fan i'm
just elated and excited um and i'm happy
that it it centered around a great
mission
um you know
i think the thing that everyone has
talked about and 100 agree with is the
success of the cookout i mean there's
lots of pieces to it but is that you
guys
sort of put something bigger than the
game in front of yourselves you know you
put
something so much bigger and so much
more important in it
and i think that really did i mean the
cookout i think is probably the most
successful alliance in the history of
big brother do you think it could be
replicated if without
having sort of like that motivating
factor of having a bigger mission
um i think it'd be very hard and i think
that um the reason why it was able to
work was because of a bigger mission i
think uh for the future big brother for
an alliance to be able to get to the end
you have to have a bigger mission if you
look at the alliances that have been
able to work well or or work pretty well
i think about the friendship um now
their bigger mission was um revenge
against cappy
and you know that's what they blindly
went after every single week but um
that's
might be a goal but that's not an actual
mission um i think it'll be very
difficult to replicate this unless you
have a mission that resonates with every
single house guest and is a shared
experience that they can all appreciate
when they walk in the door as well
um
you know obviously we did see you know
towards you and derek f had a you know
great friendship throughout uh the show
but obviously the past week or so things
got a little bit more tense um how
how do you feel about derrick f now and
how do you see your friendship
progressing outside of the house
well um i am one who i've i've every
single thing that's happened in this
game i take it in this game and i'm not
going to take it outward so um on a
personal level me and big d we'll be
we're still best friends outside of this
house um in the times where i did feel
um
you know belittled and things like that
um i stood up for myself and i made
clear that you know what no you did not
carry me um one thing about this house
is that
with you know
with you only having your game and only
having what you see um people's
perceptions can be skewed and my
gameplay was wasn't a flashy gameplay it
was
it was i i purposely
played an under the radar gameplay so
moves or things that i might have done
people wouldn't seen i've just not been
that type of person um i think what was
important for me in this game was
knowing at the end of the day what i
contributed and what i did and i knew i
deserved my seat um and i made that
clear to him and he did um
take back those words so i appreciate
that
um you know
no secret that you had a little bit of a
crush on xavier um now that you're out
of the house and you know the show the
no showmance rules are gone um could you
see you know maybe something happening
between the two of you
um i think he is a great guy and he
looks he's
quite handsome homeboy is fine okay
um
i
also will say i mean there's a lot that
i have to kind of process i haven't even
talked to my parents yet i need to
settle into the world and things and um
this is a very very unique experience
and
while i feel that we you know had a a
great um um connection and an awesome
relationship as friends in the house um
when the death settles you have to see
you know if if that will actually lead
to something um but um all in all i
think he's a great guy um i think he
would make any i think i think he's a
great guy to be honest and like i said
everyone knows i gotta question him
aaron knows he's fine he's fine
um you talked about how much you know
you're a fan of this game
uh you're such a big fan uh would you
ever play again
you know i got asked that question a lot
in the house and i was like nope nope
nope not gonna play again this is a once
a lifetime experience i'm good whatever
but there's something about coming in
third like
i it's so weird like i if you would ask
me yesterday i would say not coming back
two hours outside a finale i'm like
dang
next year year after no but some years
down the line
yes i mean if you you come in third and
you're like no i wanted to win you know
i came here to win i came here to play
and i was so close so um i think there
is a part of me that yeah we'll come
back
um who do you think you will
have a lasting friendship with
um outside of the house who do you think
you'll say the closest to
i think
all uh um that's so hard to say because
they were such i mean
i think about brittany i think about dx
i think about claire
um i part of my game was um
while i wasn't a part of the other
alliances like the royal flush or the
slaughterhouse i really worked to
develop genuine relationships with
people and i think that's what also
helped me to carry me and bring me far
um it's hard to say because this cast
was just so amazing like just
just such awesome great personalities
you know i definitely think um
as the cookout will all stay in touch um
i think um
um
how me and big d were able to work in
that final three we all really were
equally close to each other so i
definitely feel that um but it's really
hard to say at this moment i mean i i
love every single member of the cookout
i love every single member jury i love
every single member of this house so
it's a bit hard it's a bit hard yeah
um what was the thing that surprised you
the most about big brother i mean like
you said you you've watched a lot of
seasons but was there something that you
just were not expecting when you played
the game so um i came in the house
thinking that i would just do this is a
game and i do what needs to be done i
can lie i can manipulate
um
i just we're playing the human version
of chess
when you walk into this house and these
aren't chess pieces these are people's
emotions
i didn't realize how incredibly hard it
is to do that which is why i literally
just could not do it um
you a lot of players in the house and
will will tell you how
conflicting emotions of just you know
having to backstab or turn back or
manipulate things um
that's the thing that surprised me the
most i thought that i came to play so
with this being a game everything is
cool but with you having actual emotions
and
these are other people's dreams and
you're stopping those streams one by one
by voting them out the house when
they're not in your alliance man i
didn't realize how much that would grip
me and how much of an emotional struggle
it would take for
me to do this game
um you know
something
that's so great about the the game of
big brother is that you know it anybody
can play it and everyone
um
you know what would you tell somebody
who was maybe
hemming and hawing over if they should
if they should you know join big brother
like how would you describe your
experience in just a few words so my dad
uh wrote me something in my hoh letter
that really resonated with me and
something i plan to spring up in my
final speech if i got to those chairs he
said the race is not for the swift nor
is the battle for the strong but time
and chance happens to all
um i came in thinking i was going to be
a competitive threat and i could not win
a competition at all um i wasn't a
social queen i wasn't a social butterfly
and i wasn't a master manipulator um but
somebody like me was still able to get
to final three by being their genuine
self
um this season and big brother really
does work to find genuine people people
who are themselves you don't have to be
you know
a complete comp beast physical threat or
whatever to make it far into this game
if you look at the three individuals
that got to final three there were all
sorts of different types of people and
from getting to final three it really is
just
chance and hard and and timing that gets
you to those final two chairs so anyone
who is thinking of it
completely go for it i
um
i told myself you know what i want to
try and be on this show and i did it and
i'm here um i would encourage anybody to
do it like my dad said time and chance
happens to all
you